hello and welcome to this video this is
back to back that's nice against your
flow okay plate plate him or her the
game before
I totally forget how this is plain it's
been a while since I looked at it this
is not so critical I believe yeah what
unhappy if we trade cones iam got a bit
of a space disadvantage and trading a
bit makes sense let's see what your flow
is doing f3 okay not a very let's say
obvious choice but king of two was the
idea okay
you know okay I'm trying to go look be
805 a form you know probably I need to
go age six at some stage so that I can
move the h8 rook of course this is a
there's an equal position but it's a
kind of equal position that that leaves
still quite a lot of room to play in the
pawn structure is not completely
symmetrical and so on
I can't saw him maybe five I think I go
to d7 actually d7 is just a better
square being more queen side or en
turtle well okay I mean it's not it's
probably not
extremely terrible but also not good
maybe I have to get maybe have to do the
seer and gain a bit of space down
funny King but don't don't see a real
issue with this
so to play this 95 is constantly
worrying me but he never plays heard
[Music]
now g4 I got just go King g6 it's not
really a problem
I didn't threaten anything I wants to go
rookie - and then operate with this
threat I seem that that I understand
hmm I'm a knight there's still an issue
that doesn't work
I cannot go to g7 I'm such a [ __ ] it
still as this check
talk about being stupid young that was
really really really playing this badly
I had no problem at all
and now I have problems
Giroux ki7 looks normal
[Music]
maybe
let's room logistics meet okay oh I saw
the other maid he doesn't see the maid
unfortunately I can never escape and now
we see that okay yeah that was a that
was totally a totally ridiculous law
seeum I've got absolutely no issue here
nothing and completely completely gave
it away surprise that the engine gives
white an advantage to almost I thought
it should be should be okay okay yes
this is totally wrong totally do it
again I was thinking let's go g6 King g7
to step out of Knight g4 check but then
you step right into Knight f5 check so
ridiculous really
you haven't rolled yeah that it's
totally lost here a couple of mates
before of course yeah
Tyrell is a few data but I made one
pretty stupid strategic mistake is here
ninety f7 is just bad I mean when I'm I
instantly recognize that I should go to
d7 from f7 I mean not g4 is given by the
computer with okay put let's put that
aside um but this is right clearly the
far better square from f7 it is really
difficult to get denied to a good place
where do you go sorry cupboard cupboard
h6 makes no sense in particular I mean I
have to probably play a six to make the
look yeah mobile and then the night just
sucks and of course just go here and now
I have this potential square or b6 or
here it has some ideas and yeah it gives
the engine gives this as equal which i
think is fair this is a lot better
already
I mean this doesn't it didn't this
didn't lose the game but it is really AM
it was starting to problems and okay I
did not need to play a five but I felt
this is coming and maybe here this is
why I went there five yeah
now here I've got more problems than a
thought with him you played all the
moves that kept the pressure on yeah he
I should actually still do this because
after Knight f5 I have King evade yeah I
already have defended this really badly
ok thanks for watching